bienvenido al vídeo acerca de
multiplicación de decimales tomemos por
aquí un numero 7.518 aunque sabes que
pensándolo bien vamos a entrar de una
vez con los decimales entonces en lugar
de 7.518 vamos a poner 75 punto 18 y lo
queremos multiplicar por algún otro
decimal entonces vamos a poner un numero
0.97 y lo queremos multiplicar a ver y
para multiplicar dos números que tienen
números decimales lo que tenemos que
hacer es simplemente olvidarnos de que
hay un punto por aquí y hacer esta
multiplicación como si estos fueran
números enteros como si estuviéramos
multiplicando 7.518 por 97 y ya al final
vamos a ver qué es lo que tenemos que
hacer con los puntos decimales vamos a
ver como influencian esta multiplicación
que es
pero sencillo entonces pensemos
olvidémonos de los puntos decimales
7.518 por 97 entonces lo que tenemos que
hacer es multiplicar las unidades que
bueno en el fondo estas son las
centésimas pero ahorita vamos a pensar
que son las unidades tenemos que
multiplicar este 7 por todo este número
y es lo que vamos a hacer ahora 7 por 8
56 ponemos el 6 por aquí y llevamos 5 7
por 17 más 5 son 12 ponemos el 2 por
aquí y ponemos un 1 por acá de que
llevamos 17 por 5 35 más 136 ponemos el
6 y llevamos 3 7 por 7 49 más 3 52
entonces podemos ser 52 entonces lo que
tenemos que hacer es dejar un 0 aquí a
la derecha multiplicar 9
por todo este número y colocarlo a
partir de este lugar que hay entonces 9
por 8 72 y llevamos 7 que por cierto hay
que tachar estos porque son de la
multiplicación pasada y ahora 9 x 19 + 7
que llevábamos son 16 entonces ponemos
un 6 por aquí y llevamos un 9 por 5 45 +
1 46 6 y llevamos 4 y 9 por 7 63 más 4
67 entonces 67 entonces en cualquier
multiplicación de números enteros lo que
haríamos aquí es simplemente sumar estas
dos cosas 660 es seis dos más dos es
cuatro 66 es 12 llevamos 1
62 más 13 957 son 12 llevamos 16 más uno
es 7 y listo
7500 18 por 97 es 729 mil 246 cierto
bueno y ahora si viene la parte
interesante que es cuando los puntos
decimales entran en el juego porque hay
para pasar de esta multiplicación en la
que suponíamos que no estaban ahí los
puntos decimales a la multiplicación en
la que sí están los puntos decimales lo
único que tenemos que hacer es contar
cuántos números cuántas cifras hay a la
derecha de todos los puntos decimales de
esta multiplicación a ver aquí hay una
cifra a la derecha de un punto decimal
dos cifras revocase otra cifra o sea que
tenemos tres y aquí tenemos cuatro
entonces ya que contamos cuántos números
hay a la derecha de un punto decimal nos
vamos al resultado y tiene que haber
extra
de la misma cantidad de números a la
derecha del punto decimal entonces hay 1
2 3 4 aquí tenemos que poner el punto
decimal para que haya 1 2 3 4 números a
la derecha del punto decimal al igual
que los números que se están
multiplicando entonces el resultado de
esta multiplicación es 72.9 246 ahora
déjame traigo una pregunta un poco
capciosa pero muy interesante qué
pasaría si aquí en lugar de tener puntos
97 tuviera punto 970 o sea si tuviera
este 0 por aquí bueno pues resulta que
eso no afectaría a nuestro resultado
aunque eso sí hay que ser muy cuidadosos
con eso porque si tenemos aquí el cero a
la hora de hacer la multiplicación
empezamos con una fila de puros ceros
entonces aquí tendríamos otro cero por
aquí y a la hora de contar los números
que están a la derecha del punto decimal
tendríamos que contar 5
de 4 entonces aquí habría un 0 y habría
5 números a la derecha del punto decimal
pero bueno espero que esto no te
confunde este 0 solo hay que contarlo si
lo estás utilizando a la hora de
realizar esta multiplicación aunque
entonces es mejor ya dejamos de
confundirte yo lo que recomiendo es que
siempre que tengas un número que tenga
ceros a la derecha del punto decimal
olvídate de todos esos ceros y trabaja
únicamente con este decimal ahora esto
es porque los ceros están a la derecha
de cualquier número que está a la
derecha del punto decimal ok esto es
completamente distinto a si tienes un
número decimal por ejemplo 907 ahí sí
hay que tratar al cero como si fuera
cualquier número y no lo podemos
eliminar pero bueno vamos a hacer más
ejemplos de esto para que quede muy
claro a ver entonces ahora vamos a ver
un ejemplo en el que se nota a comer
sería yo con todo eso de los ceros que
no importan y todo ese relajo aunque y
entonces tenemos por allí
5.10 y queremos multiplicar por 1.09
aquí si se fijan en este número puse un
cero a la derecha del punto decimal y en
realidad este número es exactamente
igual a 5.1 pero por el momento vamos a
hacer esta multiplicación dejando este 0
tal cual en ese lugar entonces hagamos
la multiplicación asumimos que los
puntos decimales no están ahí y hacemos
la multiplicación de 510 por 109 porque
entonces 9 por 0 0 9 por 19 9 por 5 45
estamos ahora en el segundo lugar de
derecha a izquierda entonces tenemos que
poner un cero por aquí y ahora si 0 por
0 0 0 por 100 por 5 0
y ahora estamos en el tercer lugar de
derecha a izquierda
entonces ponemos dos ceros y empezamos a
multiplicar uno por cero 0 1 por 1 1 y 1
por 5 5 y ahora sumamos 000 000 + 99 es
0 055 10 + 4 5 y 5 y ahora si estamos en
el punto en el que nos acordamos que
teníamos aquí unos puntos decimales y
vemos que tenemos 1 2 3 4 números a la
derecha del punto decimal entonces
tenemos que poner el punto decimal de
tal forma que haya 4 números a la
derecha del punto 1234 o sea que lo
ponemos por aquí y entonces 5.10 x 1.09
es igual a 5.5 590 bueno ahora si vamos
a algo muy interesante
es vamos a volver a hacer esta
multiplicación pero sin poner este cero
a la derecha del punto decimal aunque
sabes que lo vamos a hacer también un
poquito distinto vamos a poner arriba
1.09 y abajo 5.1 aunque le quitamos el 0
a la derecha del punto decimal y
reacomodamos estos dos números porque
recuerda siempre que estás multiplicando
dos números la multiplicación es
exactamente igual si los cambiamos de
lugar aunque bueno entonces ahora sí a
multiplicar nos olvidamos de los puntos
decimales y tenemos aquí uno por 99 1
por 0 0 1 por 11 nos vamos al segundo
lugar de derecha a izquierda entonces
ponemos un 0 por aquí y empezamos a
multiplicar 5 por 9 45 y llevamos 4 5
por 0 0 pero llevamos 4 entonces nos
queda un 4 por acá y 5 por 1
y listo nada más tenemos que sumar 90 90
55 1 4 5 y 5 y otra vez hemos llegado a
la hora de poner los puntos decimales
tenemos por aquí 123 números a la
derecha de puntos decimales entonces
tenemos que tener 123 números a la
derecha del punto decimal y listo nos
queda exactamente el mismo número 5.559
porque los ceros a la derecha de los
números decimales no nos afectan en lo
más mínimo
ok aquí pude haber puesto como 10.000
ceros a la derecha y sería exactamente
el mismo número y bueno de hecho también
se pueden agregar números a la izquierda
o sea aquí también pudo haber puesto
muchos ceros
siempre y cuando no agregue yo ningún
uno por acá o por acá porque si
agregamos esos unos ahí si estamos
modificando muchísimo el número entonces
borremos lo bueno vamos a hacer otro
ejemplo ahora vamos a multiplicar punto
0 075 por 1.5 ok bien entonces otra vez
nos olvidamos que estamos en eso de las
multiplicaciones de decimales y creemos
que estamos simplemente multiplicando
enteros que estamos multiplicando 75 por
15 entonces hacemos 5 por 5 25 ponemos
el 5 y llevamos 25 por 7 35 pero
llevábamos 2 entonces nos queda 37 y
llevamos 35 por 0 0 pero llevamos 3
entonces tenemos que bajar el 3 por aquí
5 por 0 0
y ahora tenemos que poner un cero por
aquí y ahora sí 1 por 55 estos hay que
olvidar la elección de la multiplicación
pasada 1 por 77 1 por 0 0 y así bueno
entonces sumamos 5 0 5 5 7 12 y llevamos
un 7 más 3 10 más 1 11 11 y llevamos 100
más uno es 1 y listo
75 por 15 son mil 125 entonces ahora se
vuelve un muy buen momento para recordar
o demonios estamos multiplicando
decimales y no enteros y entonces lo que
hacemos es contar cuántos números a la
derecha del punto decimal tenemos y esos
son 1 2 3 4 5 porque entonces empezamos
a contar por aquí 1 2 3 4 y no hay sólo
cuatro números entonces cómo le vamos a
hacer para poner cinco números en la
derecha
pues resulta que lo que podemos hacer es
agregar un cero a la izquierda de
cualquier entero cierto y entonces ahora
si ponemos uno dos tres cuatro cinco
números a la derecha del punto decimal
aunque siempre que tengas que poner más
de los que tienes aquí puedes agregar
tantos ceros como quieras a la izquierda
para poder poner el punto decimal con la
cantidad correcta de números decimales
muy bien ya estamos aprendimos a
multiplicar decimales te enseñé esto de
una forma muy mecánica en la verdad
estaría más padre enseñarte lo de una
forma más profunda multiplicando por 10
y dividiendo entre 10 pero para eso
necesitamos un poco más de teoría así es
que sigue viendo estos vídeos y
eventualmente te voy a enseñar por qué
suceden todas estas cosas y por qué la
multiplicación de decimales tiene que
ser así mientras tanto estas aunque sean
formas mecánicas de multiplicar
decimales pues son muy buenas
y me parece que ya estás listo para
hacer muchos ejercicios de
multiplicación de decimales entonces
diviértete mucho